okay
well I call the meeting to order um host
Bill uh 1303 on the
subcommittee all all members are in
attendance representative McDonald is
here representative Weber representative
Missour and representative fedus who all
present and we all also recognize uh
attorney Janelle legan still a legan
right okay yeah you the these days you
never know but I was hoping it was still
a legan now we used to work together
with the Department years ago um you
still in the state stuff you still doing
the state stuff
okay okay well good
luck so again I I'll call the meeting to
order uh and basically we we're looking
at some having a work session on this
bill in relative to the estate of teest
Banu hopefully I'm pronouncing that
correctly so with that I'll open the
floor to our committee comments
representative Weber well I following up
on the discussion we had at the original
hearing um it became very clear that
setting up a dedicated
fund was not going to work the way it
was worded because we would be both
going around the iny statute and we
would be uh trying to vacate an existing
court order for intestacy so that didn't
sound like a good idea so uh what I have
done is I have drafted um an amendment
that says that the monies which is cheet
to the state through intestacy will go
to and the first
organization uh when I was doing my
original research I said appropriated to
The International Institute of New
England because they do a great deal of
work with um uh settlement and then I
got a communication from representative
TZ saying that in her experience of
centria and The International Institute
were the two so I have two
identical um amendments one of which
gives it all to The International
Institute
one of which gives it in equal
shares and I know that representative
Maser has another suggestion for our
consideration and I let OSS know that I
might be coming down and and asking for
yet
another option if if because I didn't
want to be presumptuous I just wanted to
have the language in front of us so that
all they have to do is Strike something
out and write something else in so with
that I will actually give you copies of
this so sounds good so that you have
them one
two
reallya Appropriations language because
presumably this goes on to finance which
will uh make sure the language is
correct although I did run it by Mary
Jane wner who said she thought it off to
be okay okay but she
said she always runs those by the
Legislative budget assistant which I
have not had time to do they two I got
two of the
same okay then Mr chairman also has the
how about representative Missouri do you
have two of the same
or okay yeah it should be
0450 H and
0451 H that's
correct
okay I'm not Mr Speaker
but yes that's that's tomorrow
representative Missour thank you Mr
chair um yeah so I brought forth and I
did mention it when we did our first
first committee this is when I we first
brought up the idea of Switching gears
you know away from um the department
directly to an organization this was one
I mentioned right from the room um be
because I have done a lot of volunteer
work with this group in the past um so I
can attest to the work that they do
specifically with Refugee children um in
the inner city of Manchester
um they it's incredible
they that it's all mapped out here um
but they really are they they receive
many times the only meal a day they
receive is from here um they they bring
all their friends and family and it's
their safe space um because as we know
it's difficult when you move from
another country here especially and even
on our climate and everything it's a lot
of families are struggling with figuring
things out so uh this organization does
it does it all they help with everything
I mentioned on here they even helped um
a 17-year-old uh pay for her driver's ed
so she could drive her sick mom you know
to appointments and things like that um
I was involved in
a a
donation um event at Christmas time and
supplied them with hundreds and hundreds
of presents for the kids and warm coats
so what I love about a nonprofit is the
money goes directly to benefiting the
kids there's no overhead there's no
middlemen of you know so I know you
would asked um Christina Dyer to make
copies you have it in front of you yeah
it's not an amendment it's a no it's not
an amendment I didn't know to do an
amendment I thought we I didn't know we
were that far yet I thought we were
discussing it still today and then an a
okay I don't yes and oh here yeah oh
there's okay I did put it in front of
you so I don't know how to sorry yeah
yeah I sent this last night and I'm
sorry I thought an amendment would come
out of this subcommittee so I apologize
for not putting it on um an amendment
yep they do partner with dcyf they
partner with elementary schools so when
schools can't um especially during covid
when schools were shut down Roa actually
started up a program called Excel where
they were pulling kids in and helping
them with their schooling and everything
um and that's continued on they work
with amamos health with social workers
with malal with
ois um so very connected in our city and
they literally serve hundreds and
hundreds of refugee children
uh weekly at different locations so that
they're accessible throughout the
city so just another option of of and
and I because I volunteered with them I
know uh the executive director
um they're her and they're an amazing
family and she has taken in uh foster
children and uh just incredible
individuals and all volunteer
Le
and representative
Barber they sound like a very estimable
organization
I'm a little
more comfortable with something that is
um a little less overtly
religious
um
but
um what how how do what do you mean
overtly religious what what do you mean
by that well there's this giant quote on
their web page this rock I'll build my
church in the gates of H shall not
Prevail against it okay uh
so I don't disagree with that y i just
they put I mean in what they sent me
they said they
break they they accept they have kids
come from all religions of Muslim all of
that I mean kids are coming wearing
their hijabs and I mean they're they
don't dis they don't discriminate
against anyone so it's not just a
Christian organization and it's
absolutely not they serve for all
religions and all all genders all Races
all of it so yes but that's
that's
how right these two and this one other
it splits
things in more directions
geographically and given that this is a
windfall to
everybody um perh I'm just suggesting
that that might be a way to to deal with
it I'm fine with
that specific about kids and
specifically children in
100% And they're entirely in mancher yes
yep yes so if it's acceptable
to the members of the
0418 which is the one that currently
says half
to
um Cent a half to International
Institute and I would amend that to say
one3 to a centa one third to
International Institute and oneir to uh
Roa kids of Manchester New hampsh would
that be the way I would identify
okay
any any other comments or any other
thoughts on this representative prus do
you are you comfortable with that or
yeah does the department wish to comment
sorry much shorter I'm I'm so sorry I
should
have thank you so much let me give you
those what it does is it just says that
all the m which is sheet to this
state from this gentleman's intestate
State go shall be appropriated so it's
just a plain old appropriation and it
doesn't mess up anybody's budget because
they didn't expect it to come in so it
just goes out again and then my thought
is it goes to finance and then it mess
much
button there you go once it a sheets to
the state abandoned property is okay
with giving it up with the legislation I
don't want to presume to speak for them
but um sometimes they get a little funny
about things and I'm I'm just not sure
what their process is so I just wanted
to throw that out there for
thought they can go to finance and
figure that out I figured that all of us
were concerned about setting up a whole
new bureaucracy and a whole new fund
that then had to be administered and all
the rest of it we all knew that there
are organizations that do the work that
we were hoping would be done so uh and
this doesn't require anybody to violate
a court order or or have the
legislature trying to set aside a court
order which I'm pretty sure we can't
do and um which I wouldn't vote for in
any case but um so I'm hoping this will
work
and somebody wants to complain about
it they can and will I and farbeit for
me to to throw that out there I just I'm
trying to think of the Global solution
here from the Department's perspective
this is perfect and we really appreciate
what you're doing because I think the
money is going to go a lot further to
help a lot more people this way so
that's really from the Department's
perspective it's
beautiful okay great thank you does the
other member from the Department wish to
speak or no
okay um any other
comments representative Missour I'll
just say I mean the I I've traveled all
over the world and many times to Africa
so to Rwanda specifically and when I
heard this bill brought forth um it
really did uh touch my heart so I'm
privileged to be on the subcommittee
because it really is I want to see these
children and their families that are
coming uh you know from other places
that are really struggling a lot with
cultural and everything so um if we can
come alongside all these great
organizations that are doing the work um
outside of the government um I love that
so I'm honored to be a part of that so
thank you are we thank you
yeah okay any representative frus well
also I think it's honoring his intent
have okay any other
comments okay so ultimately we're going
to be adopting one Amendment right is
that the plan right and it will it has
to be a whole new Amendment because they
won't let us just put a carrot sign and
write the name I guess in the Senate
they actually all the other body they
actually allow that to happen yeah but
uh so I am sending even as we speak the
want yeah we're executing it today yeah
so I'm just telling them we're executing
at
11: this morning we we hope it's at 11
you never know with some of our hearings
well no but I want to have this done by
11 whether whether or not um sure
absolutely and do we need to act and I
all these amendments do we just no we
don't need I'm not
off I'm not going to offer them formally
because uh it's very clear that what we
need is something slightly different but
I think we can certainly vote on the
sense of the committee subcommittee and
make a
recommendation so would it be
appropriate to um under comments and
recommendations I'll not what basically
what we've decided to do the third third
and third yep and then a motion would be
otpa but I don't have the amendment
right and and um okay
yeah you can just say amendment to be
prepared
okay
for
okay in terms of the actual motion again
it'll be otpa yep um are you moving it
representative Weber or I would be glad
to or I would would be glad to defer
either way who would like to move it why
and okay and uh oh the paper that gets
wasted in this place representative
Missour what how do you
vote representative Weber I
representative frus and I vote I Okay
so
donation
oh sorry oh I'm sorry I didn't know my
strength my I have a neighbor who takes
my New York Sunday New York Times
because she says it's much better paper
Sentinel all goes back to the universe
somewhere I like
that and I have sent the request over to
OS so my hope is that we'll get it back
um
in due course attorney Williams did you
or um it was still in session yes still
we have not adjourned
yet do you want one copy of the way we
drafted the thing um uh uh chairman uh
McDonald thank you very much uh it was a
strc Brilliance we appreciate the hard
work you folks did and I was able to see
at least the preliminary draft copy that
the the subcommittee had worked on
through attorney L Asian and also from
ABY Rogers in the audience so great work
thank you so much for getting us out of
the again the amendment you saw has it
half and half it's going to be a third a
third and a third W out kids of
Manchester is the third group so and
that was my understanding from your
discussion thank you so much okay right
so
yes it's an early bill yeah it is so we
will need to go
that they can change the the the finance
language but we really don't want them
stuff okay anything else on this uh on
hb303 this
morning if not I will uh I will close
this hearing and adjourn this meeting
you